what do you already need help with
there's a word in there that in my table
read it Wow I love the sea this is true
love isn't it when a woman helps a man
with a word well we'll do that we'll do
that later but what what's the question
it's cute though and it's cool I'm
helpful vice with Bobby
kalila hey guys I'm a big fan and a
freshman in high school I'm getting
tested soon for a DD / ADHD and I'm
almost certain that I have it I also
have a condition called tin is it 10th
tinnitus tonight and tonight it what the
Year tonight yes tonight of the year
which is a ringing in the ear my ring is
non-stop so I've never heard silence
these things combined with the fact that
I'm terrible at math have made school
very hard for me and I've caused me to
have suicidal thoughts since elementary
school I've lost hope that I'm going to
get through high school but my parents
are dead set on me going to college
the only things I'm interested in are
pursuing writing and blacksmithing
what should I do my name is Minnie Milo
well Minnie Milo blacksmithing I would
change the name of it because people
gonna think that it's you know still
that mess slavery yeah know what
blacksmithing a lot of people don't and
I wouldn't just run around in fact yeah
a lot of giving some blank reminding me
like whoa
tone it down a little you know too soon
guy too soon its 2018 so I'm gonna say
this for this guy Minnie Milo yeah first
of all having a name like Minnie Milo is
gonna make it tough for you to get a job
anywhere outside of probably being like
a disc jockey or something look man I
think you know working metal works and
doing metallurgy and all of that or
whatever you know busting out with iron
or [ __ ] around with some copper some
heated metals or whatever you know
that's beautiful stuff dude get out
there you get a special helmet you know
you get a [ __ ] torch and it probably
keeps your mind pretty focused so even
if you have a TD you can't you can't
like forget about what you're doing when
you have a [ __ ] torch going you know
so even if somebody has a dude he's
gonna focus while there's Firefly in
other hands so it sounds like that man
go build some necklaces
Brij brother whoever the [ __ ] you want
dude yeah swords yeah that's what I
would do so I feel like he's at an
advantage he knows at how old is he
19 a freshman in high school yeah he's
what 15 and he knows two things that he
loves and is good at like that's like
when I was 15 I didn't know anything
like I kind of sort of like wanted to be
in the medical field but I think I just
said that to appease my parents I didn't
know yeah so yeah you're doing just fine
about the tonight only 15 yes you got
tinnitus - what is the ringing in your
ear I get it when I'm really dehydrated
and if I'd like worked out too hard and
you just got the home and its really
really unpleasant I would go see a
really good a ENT doctor where does he
live what city he didn't say he doesn't
know probably no I mean the rain could
be pretty bad also I don't want a little
ringing in my ear during the holidays
it's the rest of the season when it
really gets on my nerve yeah but
tinnitus is a shitty but why does
tinnitus sound so [ __ ] good yeah what
do you got tinnitus yeah it sounds like
tonight's a night you're gonna [ __ ]
party yeah yeah oh man no there isn't
her tomorrow night I got yeah dude you
heard uh I'm not gonna live through the
night so this is it yeah oh you got
tinnitus yeah yeah sounds like a drug
actually yeah indie film yeah it does
sound like an indie film what are you
shooting up tinnitus oh [ __ ] somebody
else now Eric Dickerson or whatever text
me Griffin did i Griffin text yeah
nothing he just [ __ ] a centum blowing
a bubble
[Music]